if you want to know more about some of
the ties among the four three child's
play movies that you might not have
known about then stick around to the end
of this video we pick up right where we
left off yeah I'm just jumping into this
at the factory from the end of child
play to only a lot of time is passed and
it's now shut down the opening titles
are very Halloween but instead of
showing the decomposing pumpkin in
Reverse we see the plastic melting in
Reverse and also being infused with
Chucky's cursed blood or whatever I
don't know this is the dumbest method of
resurrection for Chucky yets and I think
that's saying a lot we find out that the
company behind the good guy dolls are
thinking about bringing them back and
mr. Sullivan our buddy from the second
movie makes the final call he has a
conversation with one of the other
executives it's just my wife is
expecting me this is a direct parallel
to the executive who gets killed early
on in child's play to the bad old Ibaka
of course I remembered the vodka so
apparently there's also a cutscene from
that movie where he immediately calls
his wife after that and tells her that
he'll be home late so I guess the
two-week anniversary is like how long
he's been smashing his assistant but
back to child's play three looking
around mr. Sullivan's office there are a
few set pieces that foreshadow the
events that would later take place for
example this ferris wheel she sees the
final sequence taking place at a fair
this toy army man is a hint that the
movie will take place in a military
school if we pause as the camera sweeps
by mr. Sullivan's computer you may see a
text document called Berkeley doc
alongside some numerical information
this is the same computer that Chucky
uses to find Andy's location so it seems
like the company may be keeping tabs on
him to make sure he doesn't do anything
to possibly damage the profit lines any
further that might be the creepiest
thing in the movie actually imagine this
corporation secretly tracking your every
move for eight years after one of their
dolls tried to kill you in the last two
episodes of things you missed I
mentioned the potential mistake on the
good guys boxes where it said play
partners toys instead of play pals toys
which is the name of the company in this
movie though there seemed to be more
products with play partners listed on
the box so I'm starting to think maybe
this was not a mistake maybe play
partners is the
parent company of playpals or something
Chucky attacked mr. Sullivan using an
army of his own toys a fitting death
considering he knowingly put a dangerous
product on the market in the last movie
Chucky chokes him to death and his line
just like the good old days is a
reference to him being a criminal known
as the lakeshore strangler prior to the
events of the first one we catch up with
Andy as he rolls into the military
school which looks like it's in Missouri
based on this license plate too bad for
Andy because st. Louis is boring
speaking of boring the newspaper article
that the colonel has in Andy's file is
the most boring and vague article I have
ever read and it actually just repeats
the same paragraphs over and over I
guess when you force out three movies in
three years though this is the kind of
quality you get from your art department
that being said there is something of
note in the headline text which reads
deaths still unresolved mother under
psychiatric care to suggest that
although we may not have seen it in the
other movies there may have been some
uncertainty in the public eye about
whether Andy's mom actually deserves to
be institutionalized if the case is
still open that means they may still be
investigating Andy is forced to get his
hair cut from military school and in the
barber shop there are some cadets whose
locks are on display on the wall many of
their names are jokes or pop-culture
references I saw a mr. smells mr. kurtz
stud Reilly coyote Bruce Willis and
Tommy Lee Jones
there's also a dartboard in the room
behind me sergeant Bott Nick's head this
could be a symbol for him being Chucky's
future targets especially considering
the fact that chucks has already used
darts as weapons earlier in the movie
against mr. Sullivan the sergeant tells
Andy about how the Romans invented the
military so that their enemies couldn't
grab hold of it in battle and slit their
throats that strategy didn't really work
for him though because he later meets
his fate when he gets a throat slit by
Chucky while trying to give him the buzz
as Andy's getting his trim a good guy's
episode comes on TV and it's the same
episode from the first movie we get to
see a little more of it on camera this
time around
[Music]
this kid Tyler even has a similar
reaction to Andy when he first saw the
commercial Wow so Chuck he ends up
mailing himself to Andy but Tyler ends
up opening the box instead I have
serious questions about how Chucky was
able to wrap up this package if he was
inside of it and then put that package
in the mail and pay for postage but
let's just ignore those things and get
to the part where Chucky reveals his
true self to Tyler and tries to do the
ritual to possess his body the kernel
shows up and interrupts things by taking
Chucky away I'll be back I think this is
kind of a terminator reference I'll be
back Chucky and the Terminator are both
kind of robotic killers in the way the
main difference being that Chucky is
slowly turning human Andy's roommate
Whitehurst tells Andy he needs to unpack
which may or may not be an intentional
reference to mrs. Simpson telling Kyle
to unpack in the previous movie but Andy
unpacked his stuff and we see that he's
got a magazine called playpen it seems
that Andy has grown up and moved from
playpals to playpen and the text on the
front of the magazine says come play
with me just as the good guy box says hi
I'm a good guy let's play Andy is left
alone in the room with Chucky but the
drill leader Shelton barges in and
steals the doll as a present for his
younger sister and Andy is finally smart
enough now to know that most people will
think he's insane if he tells them the
truth about Chucky so instead Andy tries
to warn Tyler that Chucky will come
after him but not before the colonel
sees Chucky moving around and has a
heart attack as a result then Chucky
slits the throat of the barber sergeant
botnik as I mentioned earlier so it all
comes down to this thing they do called
the wargames which is basically
capture-the-flag meets paintball my
parents always used to use military
school as a punishment threat whenever I
got in trouble like you better be good
or we're gonna have to send you to
military school and I always thought
that would have been like the worst
punishment you can get as a kid but
judging from this movie it looks kind of
fun I mean you get to camp out possibly
command your own little army unit with
paintballs and walkie-talkies I'd take
that over sitting in a classroom and
watching Bill Nye the Science Guy all
day but it's all fun and games until
Chucky brings in a real grenade why does
the school even have this it's like the
whole shock device from the first one
all over again
also what happened to Chucky's teeth
looks like that one lady I pointed
in the Black Christmas episode anyway
after Chucky tries to kill them all with
a grenade and Whitehurst takes one for
the team
Tyler realizes you know what maybe this
Berkeley kid was right maybe this Chucky
guy isn't such a good guy I mean
technically he is a good guy just forget
I said that
Tyler flees to the fair and Chucky makes
him go into this dark ride called the
devil's lair and let me just say this is
an awesome looking ride this is way
above the quality I would expect from a
carnival attraction this is some Haunted
Mansion level part 1 of this ride is in
a graveyard representing Chucky's
numerous victims over the three films
part two takes place in Hell
representing Andy's personal hell of
once again being hunted by Chucky after
he thought it was over eight years ago
Chucky's ritual is once again
interrupted when he dives out of the way
because he doesn't want to be seen by
the people on the ride but honestly I
don't know why I mean he's basically no
different than an animatronic he'd fit
right in there then he gets his face
sliced open by this repr sight you know
because they used a real scythe to
decorate this ride but that doesn't stop
him from making one more attempt to take
over Tyler's body during which Andy
shoots him and blows off his arm
something that happens to Chucky in all
three movies after that Andy shoots him
in the heart which makes sense because
that's what worked in the first movie
but apparently that just doesn't work
anymore because you know continuing so
the key this time is to knock Chucky
into a high-speed fan and let it shred
him up and the shot symbolically
represents Chucky falling into the pits
of hell the movie ends on another
symbolic shot it's one that I was
hesitant to bring up in my video on the
second movie the carousel in the
previous video I talked about how the
carousel represents Andy going around
and around different homes and never
settling in because Chucky always comes
after him and ruins it for him so he
continues to go around this endless
circle the music at the end seems to
suggest that Chucky isn't done for good
with the carousel telling us that it's
business as usual for Andy Barclay that
brings us to the conclusion of the
original child's play series but we've
got a remake on the way very shortly so
make sure you subscribe to see these
world so you don't miss out on the next
episode of things you missed where I'll
be covering the 2019 child's play make
sure you ring the death Bell for
notifications and I'll see you then
assuming we both survive